um so I want to show you how to do
Bluetooth in react native and the way I
discovered to be most suitable to hand
the event of nature of Bluetooth but
shortly about me margin by the way the
timer is not running just in case you
want me to stick to chime yeah thanks
I'm Martin I'm in live here in Berlin
and I will get the JavaScript engineer
and I'm currently doing node react and
react native stuff at a company called
tester and because I assume most of you
won't know test oh I quickly explain why
that is important for this talk because
the suggest was developing these kind of
devices so for example the one on the
left is a exhaust measuring device so
you plug that into a chimney of nerve of
a factory for example and it will give
you enough data to know if you are
actually within the environmental
compliance of the country you are in the
other picture is a sensor probe for
temperature measurements and that's very
often used in food compliance to just
make sure any food to eat for example
the fast food chain or a canteen is not
full of bacteria and all of these
devices basically have nowadays Wi-Fi or
Bluetooth and for Wi-Fi that's pretty
easy they talk to the cloud and you get
the data basically instantly but for
Bluetooth you need a companion app and
in the past we have build these
companion apps usually with Objective C
or Java but recently we realized while
we're doing a lot of react on the web
why not do it on direct native also with
the apps and that's how I came to do
Bluetooth and reignite of them so when I
say Bluetooth I'm actually talking about
Bluetooth Low Energy here and that is
basically a protocol called
get and GATT has four entities you
should know about if you ever handle a
Bluetooth and that client-server
character
mystic and service client and server is
basically what you already know from the
web so the client is your phone the
service a Bluetooth device on one
connects to another and once they start
exchanging information those information
live in characteristics for example one
characteristic pretty common on
Bluetooth devices is the fan
manufacturer name or for example the
battery level and these characteristics
are grouped together and services to
make that a little bit easier for us as
developers so you can imagine for
example a characteristic for temperature
readings which you would search for if
you want to reach the temperature of a
certain piece of meat for example and
the library I'm using for Bluetooth can
react nativist react native ble plx it's
a pretty straightforward library do yarn
at and if you're an iOS that's pretty it
if you're an Android you want to set up
permissions to actually use bluetooth
otherwise you will run in a lot of
exceptions and always we spent the
afternoon debugging if you look at the
documentation of this library you will
realize most of the functions either
take a call back or provider promise in
the end because I was head produces
highly asynchronous and after I
implemented the first prototypes I
realized just with pure react that's not
really too good readable it's not good
maintainable so I started looking into
what you use for the mower asynchronous
stuff and I concluded that I want to use
streams here so there's a couple of
stream libraries within the space of
JavaScript extremes the one I chose
because I like it for simplicity but
that also means that most of the stuff
you will you do with any other streaming
library does basically work also and I'm
not sure if all of you have worked with
streams before so I'm gonna quickly
explain the basic concepts just imagine
you have a timeline and in the stream
objects appear over time and disappear
and we can for example look at the talks
in this conference I like being on a
stream and like with these talks you
will not be able to actually watch to
edit at the same time so you need to be
at either one or the other jargons
that's the same in streams
you always get one object at a time and
once that's gone it's basically gone and
the beauty about streams is actually
that we can can run operations on
streams like this future for example and
that again like filters and arrays for
example will give us a new stream that
has just the items we want and for
example we can filter for just events
that happen here in the East Hall so
much about streams let's look into
Bluetooth again we will start with a
timeline the first thing you will always
do basically in any language
on any phone when you didn't want to do
Bluetooth is you need to watch the
actual state of the Bluetooth adapter
within your phone so that's basically
the little piece of hardware that is
doing all the frequency stuff and so on
you don't want to care about and it
obviously has stayed like powered on and
powered off but there's also probably
quite important one called unauthorized
and even if we have set up the
permissions within your manifest for
example as long as you don't have
permissions you will always get error
messages when you try to do something so
really important to what that state
otherwise again you're gonna debug a lot
if you don't pay attention and we can
monitor the estate with a function from
really plx that is called on state
change and instead of providing a
callback here I call a function from
extreme cold extreme from callback what
that will basically do is turn this
function into a stream so we get a
stream that will first usually show
unknown because we never used our an app
the
Bluetooth before the library is
initialized is it will not know the
Bluetooth adapter state and once
everything is done you hopefully get
powered up and again I said it's pretty
good to know during development the
state of your Bluetooth adapter so let's
assume we actually want to put some text
into our app to just show that the
Bluetooth adapter of course you know how
to display text and react native but a
stream is on the states so how do we
actually put the stream into our user
interface and the solutions hooks again
there's a couple of different
implementations of hooks called Ustream
they basically all do the same you can
just pick any but the way it works is
you plug in your stream and an initial
value and it just returns the value of
the current element in the stream and
then you can just basically put that in
your components so again the adapter
state is maybe interesting from a
development perspective but not that
relevant for users
so let's actually look on how to show
devices like the next step obviously
would be to search for devices we want
to use so we basically take the same
stream of the states and just filter for
powered on States because that's the
only one that are relevant from now on
and what we will do again is we will
take another function called start
device scan and create another stream
from these callbacks unfortunately as
you see here we actually get a stream of
streams of devices that's just the case
because we have run map on an stream and
afterwards creating a stream also so
extreme has a function called flatten
which can just flatten that down to a
stream of devices and we're ready to
show that as for example buttons and our
user interface so we now get a list of
devices we can connect to but the actual
interesting thing is going to be the
characteristics on these devices because
only that way we can read or write
information to the device
and so the first step would be to assume
that if the user clicks on one of the
buttons we have a stream with exactly
that device in it
let's call a select the device stream
and we will run a couple of map
operations basically on the stream so
the first one is connecting to the
device now you will see that I'm apart
from connecting here also stop the
scanning that is specifically relevant
to Android because most Android phones
will not allow you to connect to any
device basically if you have not stopped
scanning before so again one of these
things if you know that already it saves
you quite some time on the D button
after that we will call a second map
operation with a function called this
Bob services services and devices and
that is basically specific to our ble
plx library so the library will not know
the existing services and
characteristics after connecting so if
you just try to access them without
discovering them before you will again
just get error messages because the
library thinks they are not there in
both cases we in the end get back the
device object so the stream stays
completely the same but once we have
done these steps we can actually query
the services now the services will be an
array of services actually which means
we have one object on the stream with an
area inside which is not exactly
suitable for streams so we do do again a
combination of flatten and in this case
stream from area to turn that array into
a stream of services
and now we're actually pretty close to
the characteristics array because we can
do the same again every service has a
characteristics method that will return
areas of characteristics which we then
flatten down and then our stream looks
like this and we get any amount of
characteristics I mean I have to split
three-year usually you will get easily
50 or 60 actually on most devices so
there's one thing I for the sake of
simplicity have left out so far I
explained that you can be read from
characteristics or right to that and I
also said that most of the time you will
be easily able to for example get data
like battery level and so on from that
but there's a lot of devices that are
more complex and that's just due to the
nature that most of like previous
Bluetooth communication or also like USB
connection works fully serial meaning
you get two channels one for reading one
for writing and on these channels you
send binary messages and a lot of
devices actually simulate that by using
the characteristics you get one
characteristic for reading data and one
for writing data and that's actually how
also most of these measurement measuring
devices work I've showed you before and
when it reversed the code for preparing
the talk I realized the protocol we are
speaking there is proprietary and I kind
of can't show it here so you might
realize the buttons are called like
stars robots so I will assume now I'm
speaking an imaginary protocol with the
imaginaries that was robots which
happened to work very similar to the one
I used to implement so let's assume we
have a VBA robot here and we want to
have that roll around the room and so to
control that we just add four more
buttons with arrows for all the
directions and now we can again assume
with the buttons that we have stream of
these patterns and that stream would
something looks something like that
you see all the four arrows and a stop
symbol
the basic idea being that when you press
the button it sends the arrow and when
you release the button it will send the
stop signal so the robot is not crashing
in any walls
unfortunately I mean these are symbols
you really can't send that to a robot so
we need to convert that into something
more technical I've chosen vectors here
so basically the first parameter is the
speed the second one is the angle so for
we're going to the fixed speed of 80
here and then the angles and to stop we
just speak to zero again that's already
technical but it's not yet binary so
let's use some method called roll and
turn that into actual binary packages so
now we are technically done and could
send these information off to the robot
unfortunately there's one specific about
Billy plx a dozen you use byte arrays
but instead base64 encoded strings and
so we need to actually encode that with
base64 which is slightly annoying during
different development but it works fine
so now how do we send that to the robot
we had the stream of characteristics and
we can filter on that for specific
characteristic for sending off stuff and
then we can use a method called combine
and you can see on the top timeline or
does is basically it takes both streams
and combines the object together so
whenever there's a new event coming a
one stream and will memorize the
previous event on the other stream and
combine them together to be a new event
and we're gonna need that because once
you register a listener on this new
stream you can actually take the
characteristic for sending and the
command you want to send and basically
use the write with response method here
to send that around
that's all pretty nice and we can send
our data to the robot but actually the
day the rose never setting your data
back and if you imagine for example it
would run into a wall and you are
standing around the corner you wouldn't
even realize so let's implement some
collision detection basically saying if
the robot runs in a wall we can show
this emoji just for the user to know and
the way we do that is again we take the
characteristic stream and we pick the
characteristic for reading data and
again we use Eckstrom from Kovac but
this time we call a method called
monitor on the characteristic monitors
basically doing it will give you all
incoming packages into our stream and
that will look something like this you
realize again we are at base 64 so we
will need to decode that and now we need
to do some interpretation on these
packages so it's pretty fair to assume
actually that there's gonna be more
packages than just collision detection
so for example I don't know the robot
notifies about this battery level or
Wi-Fi signal swings or whatever so let's
assume the third byte in the binary
array is an identifier for the package
type so what we can do basically is pick
the third byte and return that on the
stream if you haven't worked with data
view it's pretty nice and built in
JavaScript class for handling binary
data and that's basically our collision
stream we can just filter for the
packages we need which show us a
collision and again plug that into our
user interface to show the emoji
now when I was researching again for
this talk I pretty soon found there is
actually a bb-8 robot you can control
via bluetooth it's made by company
material you might know them from these
balls that are usually used for playing
with cats and it works pretty fine and
by coincidence that exactly works with
the code I showed you before
unfortunately it's well the bottle is
bigger like she did in the robot and you
see it running around the stage here so
I made a video but if you're going to be
later at the party or grip me later at
the conference I have with me and you
can take a look play around with that if
you want yeah let me show you the video
let's see on which screen this yeah of
course on the wrong one give me one
moment - left right oh that looks good
so you can see the app has put it up the
robot was discovered and once it turned
purple it actually connected now I'm
running it a little bit around
I keep getting quite confused because of
having the phone in one hand and the
tablet in the other one and you see I
crashed it into the wall and the emoji
appears so let's see if I can get back
here here we go
and that's basically it I put the code
on github for the robot but if you any
device you have basically it's fine to
trying on Bluetooth and if you try that
out I hope you have if you haven't
worked with streams at least see that
it's possible for some applications to
use streams and yeah thanks for watching
and enjoy the rest of the day
[Applause]
you